bonjour à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
sur public Scéna tout au long du mois de
septembre je vous propose de voir et de
revoir les temps forts de la séance et
des auditions lors de la dernière
session parlementaire car tout au long
du mois de septembre et bien les
sénateurs sont absents du Palais du
Luxembourg ils sont en Agne pour
préparer les prochaines élections
sénatoriales qui se tiendront le 28
septembre et qui permettront de
renouveler la moitié de la Haute
Assemblée retour aujourd'hui au 4 juin
dernier à l'audition de Guillaume Pépi
le directeur général de la SNCF avait
été auditionné par la commission du
développement durable du Sénat il avait
été auditionné à propos de la réforme
ferroviaire un texte qui permettait de
réorganiser les forces de Réseau ferré
de France et de la SNCF
afin d'améliorer leur rentabilité de
préparer l'ouverture à la concurrence un
texte qui après de nombreuses grèves au
début de l'été avait finalement été
adopté par le Parlement au mois de
juillet avant d'être définitivement
promulgué au mois d'août l'audition de
Guillaume Pépi intervenait également
quelques jours après la fameuse affaire
des t trop larg pour leur RAM une
affaire qui va coûter 50 millions
d'euros et qui imposait de raboter 1300
qu de gare tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition c'était début juin au
Sénat monsieur le Président bienvenue
euh vous dire que votre audition était
très attendu mais ça c'est pas un scoup
puisque évidemment nous sommes
tous aujourd'hui en attente
d'information pour cette fameuse réforme
ferroviaire qui devrait être examinée au
Sénat première semaine de
juillet il nous faut donc dès à présent
puisque euh nous avons peu de temps euh
à voir sur cette réforme toutes les
précisions que vous pourrez nous donner
et vous savez que dans cette
commission le sujet de l'aménagement du
territoire de la mobilité du devvelement
durable sont des sujets majeur de cette
commission et par conséquent euh cette
réforme pour nous est de la plus grande
importance alors nous savons que
euh quelques grandes lignes que nous
avons pu avoir euh laisse encore
beaucoup de points à clarifier que des
arbitrages vont être nécessaires que la
réforme du modèle social est importante
et bien sûr que le transport ferroviaire
constitue pour l'avenir de notre pays un
élément extrêmement important et bien
sûr cette réforme non seulement é
absolument indispensable mais peut-être
qu'elle constitue une des dernières
chances de ver le rail français on sait
que le déficit
aujourd'hui est d'environ 40 milliards
et que si nous ne faisons rien il
augmente d'un milliard et demi tous les
ans et donc il nous faut
absolument que nous puissions arrêter
cette
hémorragie j'ajoute qu'un grand nombre
d'élus locaux sont en attente des
attentes fortes et parfois regrettent
que
ces attentes n'aient aucune réponse et
on voit avec
inquiétude des lignes capillair de fret
ou des lignes secondaires de de
voyageurs qui sont dans un tel état
qu'on pense qu'elles vont disparaître
donc bien sûr nous avons des
spécialistes dans notre commission
particulier notre rapporteur monsieur
michel Teston qui ne manqueront pas de
vous interroger et bien entendu si Louis
peut se libérer je pense que nous
le verrons aussi il vient tout à l'heure
parfait ce ne sont pas les seuls et donc
j'espère que cette audition nous
permettra euh d'avoir donc toutes les
informations nécessaires avant de nous
engager dans notre travail de
parlementaire j'ajoute tout de suite
pour mes collègues que à la fin du sujet
principale de cette audition qui est la
réforme ferroviaire bah si vous le
voulez bien monsieur le Président nous
dirons deux mots des des problèmes de
quai et de rame terre mais nous le
ferons une fois que nous aurons terminé
l'audition concernant la réforme
ferviaire monsieur président sans plus
attendre je vous donne la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames et messieurs merci beaucoup de
de cette opportunité que vous m'offrez
de de m'exprimer devant vous sur la
réforme ferroviaire je veux tout de
suite préciser que la réforme
ferroviaire c'est le projet du
gouvernement et du
ministre qui est présenté devant
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat et
donc je n'interviens ici que comme
responsable de la SNCF qui est
l'opérateur public national de transport
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguité je
m'exprimerai de ce point de vue-là et de
ce point de vue là seulement peut-être
euh pour utiliser la dizaine de minutes
que vous me proposez je voudrais essayer
de de
dire si le Parlement adopte une réforme
du système
ferroviaire dans les prochaines semaines
qu'est-ce que la SNCF peut elle-même
apporter avec cette réforme et donc avec
votre autorisation je n'entrerai pas
dans le détail de la proposition que
fait le gouvernement au Parlement je
pense que c'est pas mon rôle je suis pas
là pour la défendre ou la critiquer ou
l'amander ça c'est le rôle du
gouvernement et du Parlement en revanche
ce que je peux dire c'est ce que la
SNCF devrait faire si cette réforme est
adoptée et au
fond les choses me semble-t-il de ce
point de vue là sont sont assez
claires d'abord c'est à nos yeux
d'opérateur ferroviair c'est une réforme
qui est faite qui doit être faite pour
améliorer la vie des voyageurs et des
chargeurs il faut jamais perdre de vue
cet objectif central c'est de rendre un
meilleur service public ferroviaire et
je pense que c'est ce que le pays attend
de la SNCF si la réforme est votée très
concrètement dès lors qu'il y a un
nouveau fonctionnement qui est prévu
qu'est-ce que nous allons faire un des
travaux mieux organisés et tout le monde
sait qu'il y a un mur de travaux sur le
réseau aujourd'hui
de une vraie
cohérence système ça veut dire une
préoccupation
constante de réaliser le meilleur lien
entre l'infrastructure et le ou les
transporteurs vous avez cité l'affaire
du régiolist j'imagine qu'on rendra tout
à l'heure et puis et puis le plus
important améliorer l'utilisation du
réseau on a un et un seul réseau ce ce
réseau doit se partager entre des
travaux sa maintenance son amélioration
et puis des circulations et pour avoir
vécu ces 15 dernières années deux
établissements publics de l'État qui
étaient face à
face au lieu d'être côte à côte et qui
se sont livré c'est vrai pendant
certaines années à une guerre ouverte
on voit bien que l'utilisation du réseau
n'était pas optimale tout le monde
connaît des tas d'exemples où des
travaux prévus annulai des trains mais
finalement les travaux n'avaient pas
lieu et tout le monde connaît des trains
qui devaient circuler empêchant des
travaux mais finalement le train ne
circulait pas et donc de l'avis générale
le réseau ferroviaire français est
sousutilisé faute de coordination
entre ceux qui a celui qui a la la
charge du réseau et ceux qui ont la
charge de faire des transports en terme
chiffré si la réforme est adoptée par le
Parlement moi je m'engagerai à ce que la
régularité des trains
augmente je dirais d'un point
supplémentaire tous les 2 ans
c'est-à-dire un demi- pointo par an sur
les 4 à 5 ans qui viennent c'est un pari
audacieux parce qu'on est dans une
période de travaux tous aimutes mais je
suis tellement convaincu qu'on peut
mieux faire fonctionner le système que
je prendrai cet engagement d'un
demi-point de régularité supplémentaire
par an chaque année deuxièmement pour
les élus alors là les choses sont
particulièrement frappantes tous les
élus de France ont vécu ces dernières
années l'incroyable complexité du
système ferroviaire dans lequel les élus
sont ballotés renvoyer de gare et
connexion vers l'infrastructure de
l'infrastructure vers le transporteur
bon ça n'est pas décent ça n'est pas
efficace ça a bloqué un nombre
considérable de projets d'aménagement
urbain et foncier et par conséquent
l'engagement que je prends devant vous
si la réforme est votée c'est que nous
allons unifier la gestion du patrimoine
foncier et immobilier
immédiatement immédiatement c'est-à-dire
que au-delà du régime juridique au-delà
des personnes juridiques nous allons
faire dès le lendemain de la réforme
avec cpoport un plateau commun qui sera
l'interlocuteur unique de tous les élus
au plan local et national pour
simplifier les problèmes de foncier et
d'immobilier il y aurait bien d'autres
exemples à donner mais je je celui-là
est celui qui me paraît le le le le plus
frappant donc simplifier la vie des élus
et des collectivités pour accélérer les
opérations d'aménagement et évidemment
derrière tout ça il y a la
valorisation pour le logement social a
les équipements collectifs et il y a un
meilleur traitement des délaissés vous
témoignez tous que dans toutes les
agglomérations dans toutes les villes il
y a des délaissés
ferroviaires qui sont dans un état pas
possible qui posent des problèmes aux
élus et sur lesquels nous allons nous
engager vis-à-vis de vous à les traiter
lorsque la réforme sera votée trème
point de vue cette fois-ci que peut
comment peut-on s'engager vis-à-vis des
autorités organisatrices
moi ce que j'espère c'est que dans votre
sagesse vous ferez des autorités
organisatrices notamment régionales des
autorités organisatrices de plein
exercice et qu'on sortira du du milieu
du gay actuel où on ne peut pas vraiment
dire que celui qui paye décide c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça chacun
sait par exemple que les tarifs des TER
chaque année l'augmentation des tarifs T
est fixé dans une réunion
interministérielle de l'État mais
s'applique aux régions c'est un système
qui est un peu paradoxal chacun sait que
juridiquement les trains sont payés à
100 % par les régions mais
n'appartiennent pas aux régions d' une
complexité qui est quand même assez
invraisemblable donc oui il y a une
simplification une clarification
nécessaire autour de qui paye décide et
des
autorités organisatrices de pleine
exercice puisque je m'exprime ici comme
responsable de l'opérateur j'indique
aussi que sur la question de la
concurrence l'Union européenne a
commencé à parler puisque l'Union
européenne a adopté un texte au
Parlement européen qui fixe des
échéances en 2019 et
2023 le texte proposé par le
gouvernement ne traite pas la question
de la préparation à la concurrence mais
moi j'indique qu'au vu de l'opérateur il
faudra ultérieurement traiter de cette
question car souvenons-nous quand
l'Union européenne a a ouvert le fret à
la concurrence en 2007- 200008 notre
pays était malheureusement totalement
impréparé et donc le choc de l'ouverture
à la concurrence a été massif recul de
tous les trafics fret quasi faillite de
frit SNCF donc il faudra se préparer à
cette ouverture à la concurrence par
exemple les personnels nous interrogent
sur une belle question la SNCF en 2023
perd un
marché que se passe-t-il est-ce que les
personn SNCF qui travaille sur cette
ligne sont transférés au nouvel
opérateur comme c'est le cas dans les
villes
ou est-ce que comme c'est le cas en
Allemagne celui qui a perdu le
marché récupère si je puis dire
l'ensemble de ses salariés pour les
affecter à d'autres lignes il y a
plusieurs systèmes
possibles ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on ne
peut pas attendre que ça se produise en
2023 pour avoir traité de cette question
euh et je dis simplement c'est pas
l'urgence hein on est en 2023 mais il
faudra aborder cette question 4e point
de vue euh le point de vue
économique avec JAC Rapoport nous nous
partageons la même
analyse le projet de loi tel qu'il est
permet aux deux établissements publics
de stabiliser leurs dettes à une
échéance qui est probablement de l'ordre
de
2020 permet de stabiliser la dette mais
de la stabiliser à un niveau très élevé
c'est donc une première étape cette
première étape elle est déjà
fondamentale parce que comme l'a rappelé
notre président aujourd'hui ça dérive ça
dérive suivant le loyer de l'argent
entre 1 milliard et demi et 3 milliards
et suivant le nombre de projets de
grande vitesse donc l'objectif de
stabilité il est ambitieux il suppose
trois choses 1
que notre pays réduise la voilure sur
les nouveaux projets de Ligne à Grande
Vitesse non pas ceux qui sont en cours
mais les futurs là la commission dur Ron
mobilité 21 et cetera de il suppose que
le système ferroviaire fasse un effort
de performance sans précédent et avec
jacqureapoport nous nous engagerons si
la loi est
votée nous nous engagerons
à faire 1 milliard d'euros d'économie
sur la facture ferroviaire de la France
en quelques années de l'ordre de 3 à 5
ans donc ça c'est l'engagement que nous
nous proposons de prendre de faire ce
milliard d'économie 500 millions du côté
du réseau 500 millions du côté de
l'entreprise de mobilité enfin la
trème condition si je puis dire c'est
que l'État
accompagne cette stabilisation de la
dette c'é une question qui est en cours
de discussion et il m'appartient pas
évidemment ici de de de la commenter sur
la façon dont l'État pourrait ou ou
pourrait ne pas accompagner cette étape
mais ce point de vue là est absolument
essentiel car s'il n'y avait pas cet
objectif de stabilisation de la dette la
réforme n'atteindrait pas l'objectif de
consolider le système ferroviaire et je
dis en toute honnêteté que je pense
qu'il y aura d'autres étapes après c'est
une première étape de stabiliser il y en
aura d'autres mais faisons déjà celle-là
elle est ambitieuse 4ème point de vue le
le point de vue
social je le disais tout à l'heure on ne
peut
pas préparer l'avenir du système
ferroviaire en faisant l'impasse sur les
règles sociales du système à ce
moment-là ça veut dire que les cheminaux
sont la la variable d'ajustement et
qu'au fond on laisse les questions des
salariés sans réponse le projet de loi
de ce point de vue là comporte une
disposition
fondamentale maintien du statut pour les
chemineaux qui sont au
statut comme d'ailleurs à EDF à la météo
dans toutes les réformes législatives de
notre pays le statut des personnels en
place a été maintenu et deuxième partie
du projet de loi prescription par la loi
de la négociation d'une convention
collective applicable à 100 % des
salariés du secteur
cette convention collective elle fixe
elle les règles d'emploi la façon dont
on fait les 35 he les amplitudes les
repos tout ce qui fait la vie
quotidienne des cheminau du public ou
des cheminau du
privé cette disposition là nous la
soutenons avec Jacques Rapoport
fermement parce que nous il nous semble
que c'est la préparation de l'avenir
pour l'information du
Sénat cette discussion c'est déjà amorcé
SEP syndicats sont autour de la
table SEP syndicats tous les salariés
sont représentés et nous avons déjà
obtenu ce qui est un point fondamental
nous avons déjà obtenu un accord de
méthode ce qui est un premier pas très
important cela signifie que les
syndicats et le patronat se sont engagés
sous l'autorité de l'État dans cette
négociation en partageant les objectifs
en partageant la façon de négocier donc
c'est comm même de de bonne augure même
si chacun sait que ça sera compliqué
enfin il pour pas être trop long deux
autres petites
annotations d'abord la question
européenne dans cette même salle je me
souviens lors de de mon audition pour
mon renouvellement nous avions parlé de
ces questions et je me souviens que on
était dans la situation où il nous
semblait que l'Union européenne avait
pris des positions très tranché un peu
dogmatique en disant seule la séparation
sera acceptée à à terme dans l'Europe la
France avec l'Allemagne a joué son rôle
la France par la négociation l'Allemagne
plutôt par le rapport de force et le
vote du Parlement européen qui est
intervenu en
février laisse les deux systèmes ouvert
en
Europe le système
intégré que vous vous apprêtez à
examiner et un système séparé que
d'autres pays ont choisi et ces deux
systèmes
sont jugés possibles par l'Europe à la
condition qu'il y ait un régulateur tant
mieux vive l'ARAF hein il y a une Araf
en France et c'est un bien qui est un
régulateur du système ferroviaire et
deuxième condition que ceux qui ont
choisi l'unité respecte le principe de
non discrimination des entreprises
privées ferroviaires et j'indique ici
que et jacqura popor et moi-même nous
sommes totalement engagé à respecter le
principe de non discrimination des
entreprises privées ferroviaires et nous
le ferons parce que c'est la condition
d'existence d'un système
intégré dernier mot
peut-être et qui est pas le le le moins
important pour nous qu'est-ce que cette
réforme si vous la votez peut apporter à
l'activité à l'exportation et à l'emploi
et pour moi ça c'est un point essentiel
on ne le sait pas mais
laasncf est un champion industriel
français européen et international
elle fait aujourd'hui presque 10
milliards de volumes d'affaires hors de
France pour certaines de ces activités
les activités de logistique les
activités de métro de tramois la moitié
de notre activité est faite en Europe ou
ailleurs dans le monde et nous sommes le
deuxième groupe mondial de service de
mobilité derrière le groupe allemand
deutscheban ces activités sont en très
forte croissance car dans le monde
entier l'urbanisation les grandes
métropoles exige des
solutions écologiques et accepable en
terme énergétique de transport et de
déplacement et donc ces activités sont
vitales dans le monde entier et c'est un
des points forts de notre pays et
en ayant une organisation nouvelle du
système ferroviaire nous agirons comme
pardon du mot qui est un peu barbare un
acteur du système ferroviaire parce
qu'on ne vend pas le savoir-faire
français en tranche de salami on apporte
des solutions à des villes à des
entreprises en leur disant oui nous
savons nous les Français faire un
tram-traain qui a telle caractéristique
et le système entier et nous arrivons
avec des ETI françaises nous arrivons
avec des entreprises de génie civil nous
arrivons avec des constructeurs de
matériel français et donc cette
dimension offensive de champion
industriel c'est me semble-t-il la
finalité des finalités pour vous citer
une anecdote un jour la chancelière
allemande a l'occasion de nous
rencontrer un certain nombre d'entre
nous et nous a dit mais vous savez en
Allemagne la deutsoban son
fonctionnement c'est un consensus
politique en Allemagne queles que soient
les coalitions le fait d'avoir un
champion industriel allemand elle n'a
pas cité le lien avec Siemens mais elle
aurait pu citer aussi le lien avec
simemens en disant tout ça ça permet à
l'Allemagne de jouer un rôle
prépondérant dans le dans les systèmes
de transport en Europe et dans le monde
et donc cette dimension là qui est
créatrice d'emploi qui équilibre le
commerce extérieur qui est créatrice de
croissance c'est une finalité
extraordinairement importante voilà ce
que je voulais dire en introduction
monsieur le Président j'ai peut-être été
un tout petit peu trop long pas du
tout première question est posée par
Monsieur michel Teston et merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président Pépi
je vais essayer de pas être long mais
toutefois je souhaite quand même vous
poser euh quatre questions deux qui
portent sur l'organisation actuelle et
l'émission actuelle de la
SNCF une qui est relative aux relations
avec les régions qui sont très investies
en tant qu'autorité organisatrice des TR
express régionaux et je ne vous poserai
qu'une seule question sur le projet de
la réforme ferroviaire pour laisser aux
collègues la possibilité de s'exprimer
largement cette question malgré tout est
centrale vous l'avez évoqué c'est celle
de l'aspect financier de la réforme
ferroviaire alors
d'abord première question qui concerne
finalement l'organisation actuelle
j'ai mené en tant que rapporteur du
procal de réforme ferroviaire de très
nombreuses auditions depuis plusieurs
mois et j'ai été frappé ainsi que celles
et ceux qui ont participé à ces
auditions par les critiques formulées
par un certain nombre de
interlocuteur sur la gestion par
activité qui selon ces personnes
auraient profondément désorganisé
l'entreprise et alors je citerai un
exemple qui est souvent cité il y aurait
une grande difficulté pour ne pas dire
une impossibilité pour un conducteur
affecté à l'activité frite de pouvoir en
cas de nécessité conduire un TER même si
le dit conducteur a toutes les
habilitations pour conduire un train
donc autorisé à circuler à 160 km/h ce
qui est le cas pour les les
TER 2è question vous êtes chargé par
convention avec l'État euh de la mission
essentielle en matière d'aménagement du
territoire des trains d'équilibre du
territoire or ces trains sont très peu
fréquentés et ils sont peu en raison de
leur manque
d'attractivité matériel roulant ancien
horaire mal adapté alors que
comptez-vous faire pour finalement les
rendre attractifs à l'instard de ce qui
est fait dans de très nombreux autres
États de l'Union européenne où le terme
train d'équilibre du territoire n'existe
pas mais où ces trains existent par
contre bien trisème question elle me
permettra de faire la transition avec le
projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire
c'est la situation avec la question donc
du projet de réforme ferroviaire et la
situation financière du système
ferroviaire c'est la place des régions
dans le dispositif quand on regarde le
projet de loi dans sa forme initiale
finalement la place des régions n'est
que peu reconnue et alors quelques
avancées sont possibles à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat quelques-unes ont
été esquissées à ma connaissance la
semaine dernière lors de l'examen par la
commission Développement Durable de
l'Assemblée nationale donc euh du côté
de la SNCF que comptez-vous faire pour
répondre aux critiques des régions et en
particulier sur le manque de
transparence de vos
comptes et puis la dernière question
elle est au cœur de la réforme
ferroviaire qui s'engage dans un
contexte un peu pesant semble-t-il si
l'on en croit les
informations sur euh des euh préavis de
grève qui auraiit été déposé par deux
organisations syndicales représentatives
euh la question financière est bien un
élément central de la réforme or je dois
dire que malgré les informations que
vous nous avez donné celle donné par le
président de RFF celle donnée par le
secrétaire d'État au transports la
plupart n Inter locuteur aux auditions
n'ont pas été convaincus du tout par les
économies annoncées et attendu
finalement de la réforme euh donc le
fait qu'on constitue un gestionnaire
unifié d'infrastructure en regroupant
SNCF Infra la DCF et puis RFF ne leur
paraît pas finalement suffisant pour
assurer les économies attendus et donc
ces interlocuteurs ont quelques doutes
sur la stabilisation de la dette à
laquelle vous avez fait allusion dans 3
ou 4 ans euh même si effectivement cette
stabilisation vous même vous l'avez dit
devrait se situer à un très haut niveau
ce qui pose le problème de savoir sur la
part de la dette du système ferroviaire
et en particulier de RFF s'il n'y a pas
une dette d'État mais c'est une autre
question qu'on abordera pas aujourd'hui
puisqu'elle nous dépasse pour l'instant
voilà je n'ai pas été trop long monsieur
le Président de la Commission monsieur
le Président de la SNCF je pense que les
collègues poseront de nombreuses
questions que j'auris POS mais il est
normal que vous leur laisse la
possibilité de s'exprimer merci Monsieur
Teston Monsieur Louis Nigre bien
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président le monsieur Teston parle d'or
le climat est pesant il est pesant et
c'est pas la faute à Michel ni à Louis
on constate que nous avons aujourd'hui
un préavis de grève donc cette réforme
qui est faite par un gouvernement de
gauche ne recueille pas semble-t-il la
sentiment de sa base bon c'est déjà un
problème
politique c'est un problème politique
d'abord oui j'ai encore j'ai encore le
droit d'exprimer mon opinion Michel
voilà allons allons messieur c'est c'est
c'est c'est pas un duo c'est pas un duo
c'est une la parole est à Monsieur
louich pas de faire un duo là de hein
s'il vous plaît monsieur vous reprenez
le fil de votre question merci monsieur
le Président voilà donc nous avons déjà
un contexte qui n'est pas porteur à ce
niveau-là qui pose problème parce que y
compris la base
renacle mais il y a pas que la base
parce que si on prend cette réforme
attendue je pense que et quand j'emploie
le mot attendue elle est attendue par
tout le monde les assis du ferroviaire
ont bien montré tout l'intérêt de S dans
une réforme et là c'était consensuel il
faut une réforme quelle est la réforme
qu'on doit faire c'est là-dessus où
peut-être on se divisera moi ce que je
constate c'est que dès lors que l'on met
en place un état stratège ça me convient
je trouve que à ce niveau-là et
notamment au niveau du réseau mais ça va
avoir des incidences dans ma démarche
parce qu'à ce moment-là le président du
directoire c'est le président du
Réseau après vous avez une Val tion par
le Parlement qui est souhaitable d'une
vision globale comme on le trouve en
Allemagne où vous avez t les 5 ans la
possibilité de remettre à niveau votre
plan et en tout état de cause qu'il y
ait une validation j'allais dire
annuelle c'est quelque chose qui
passerait par le Parlement et qui me
paraît nécessaire pour atteindre cette
fameuse transparence la réunification du
juu très bien tout le monde est d'accord
là-dessus on a le sentiment vraiment
qu'il fallait se rassembler qu'il
fallait mettre les équipes ensemble pour
arriver à de meilleurs résultats ensuite
je reprendrai ce qui a été dit par
michel Teston la place des régions me
laisse songeur j'ai pas très bien
compris où elles étaient ce qu'elle
pouvait faire elle manque d'argent en
plus mais je pense que les régions
méritent d'être des autorités de plein
exercice et je vous rejoins sur ce
point-là je pense qu'il faut à partir de
là leur donner les moyens de leur
politique pour qu'on soit cohérent avec
nous-même on a également alors
maintenant dans les questions que je
pourrais poser pour faire vite
euh je trouve malheureusement un certain
nombre de de problèmes premier c'est
avec la RAF avec ce fameux régulateur
que tout le monde attend appelle de nos
vœux et à qui d'entrer de jeu on coupe
les ailes on lui il a plus d'avis
conforme il a plus qu'un avis motivé
voilà donc voilà quelque chose qui moi
m'interpelle directement je l'ai dit au
ministre en personne j'ai dit attends je
comprends pas bon ensuite la dette la
dette c'est un sujet non
négligeable et bien la dette vous vous
engagez me dites-vous pour un milliard
d'économie en quelques années si on
arrive et je je vous remercie merci pour
votre honnêteté intellectuelle si on
arrive à stabiliser cette dette ça sera
déjà un grand progrès voilà où nous en
sommes en France
aujourd'hui la dette est en dizaines de
milliards d'euros et tout ce qu'on peut
viser aujourd'hui dans le meilleur des
cas et ben c'est la stabilisation de la
dette je vous parle pas de la résolution
du problème qui est la dette personne
n'en parle et pourtant tout le monde
sait que ça c'est un vrai problème de
fond et qu'il appar
pas du tout bon ensuite vous avez ce que
l'Europe a appelé les et donc c'est
c'est un corollaire avec le Ju c'est ce
qu'on a appelé les murailles de Chine
cette indépendance de ce groupement des
infrastructure unifié làon et bien si
nous n'avons pas la garantie d'une
autonomie et d'une indépendance des flux
financiers
euh je serai
je m'opposerai à ce type de réforme je
pense qu'il est souhaitable et
nécessaire qu'il y ait là de véritables
murailles de Chine particulièrement
impénétrable il me restera ensuite à
vous poser la question de savoir où vous
situez les élus et les usagers dans
cette démarche là parce que j'estime que
les élus et notamment les parlementaires
le Parlement qui vote les réformes qui
vote les lois qui vote le budget qui
vous permet de
disons d'avoir ensuite un budget en
équilibre en fin d'année a besoin ils
ont besoin ses élus d'avoir leur place
et je le souhaite également ardemment
les
usagers nous sommes tous tous au service
de nos concitoyens et donc je
souhaiteraiis les retrouver et ensuite
une petite question de taquine que
devient la gouvernance des
Gard Monsieur François grigon Francis
pardon grillant c'est pas grave merci
monsieur le Président alors en préambule
je voudrais dire que pour bien
m'imprégner de cette réforme et pour
faire des comparaisons j'ai interrogé
des responsables de laadb aussi parce
que nos deux grands champions étant
allemand et français je trouve qu'il
était intéressant de faire des
comparaisons alors je voudrais aborder
le problème sous deux angles ce qui est
dans la loi et ce qui est hors la loi ce
qui est hors la loi je veux dire ce qui
est en dehors de la loi pardon
excusez-moi alors ce qui est dans la loi
j'avais des doutes au départ sur la
gouvernance avec deux personnes au
Directoire bien et à la réflexion quand
je regarde ce qui s'est passé en
Allemagne où on a en fait le comité dbag
et mobility logistique AG on a là-bas
deux groupes mais avec le même directeur
on a deux groupes parce qu'à l'époque il
faut se le rappeler en Allemagne on
voulait privatiser l'activité de
l'opérateur ferroviaire le faire rentrer
en bourse s'il y avait pas eu cette idée
on aurait qu'un seul groupe donc moi il
me semble que ce qui est prévu dans
notre loi aujourd'hui est tout à fait
cohérent par rapport à ce qui se passe
en Allemagne et que nous n'avons pas à
faire plus séparé ce qui nous
pénaliserait par rapport à eux et comme
nous sommes les deux grands en Europe
moi je trouve que c'est quand même pas
mal deuxièmement la RAF alors au départ
dans le
texte j'étais un peu choqué par le rôle
de l'ARF qui n'avait plus que
un avis qui n'était pas conforme mais je
crois que tout a été
rectifié je pense que c'est à la
satisfacation de tout le monde et que
l'ARAF retrouve son rôle troisième sujet
le transfert au au réseau de toutes les
infrastructures qui sont en particulier
chez SNCF mobilité aujourd'hui
j'aimerais avoir et là c'est une
question monsieur le Président
j'aimerais savoir si tout est bien
transféré pour qu'il n'y ait pas la
tentation de certains de faire des
blocages sur le terrain assez insidieux
parfois et je pose en particulier le
problème des cours de marchandises pour
que les opérateurs de fret puissent y
accéder librement facilement sans aucune
contrainte ainsi que le problème des
facilités
essentielles en ce qui concerne ce qui
est plutôt hors la loi ou qui n'est pas
traité dans la loi pardon il y a le
problème de la dette on l'a dit 42
milliards si vous pouviez me confirmer
35 pour RF 7 pour la
SNCF je dis simplement à mes collègues
que chez la DB pour un chiffre
d'affaires plus important c'est 17
milliards donc j' pour qu'on ait ce ce
chiffre en comparaison donc j'espère
j'espère que l'État va continuer à
garantir cette chose sinon ce serait
véritablement une catastrophe mais ça
c'est une question qu'on posera au
ministre toujours dans le domaine
financier j'ai quand même une
interrogation si mes souvenirs sont bons
les sillons sont subventionnés à 40 %
aujourd'hui pour tous les opérateurs et
jusqu'en
2015 qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on ne
continuait pas à faire cela est-ce que
tout le transport de fret serait
définitivement mort est-ce que tous les
tout le transport irait sur les camions
ça c'est une question très importante et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur ce
sujet reste le problème du décret du
décret qui va tout définir des
négociations qui ont lieu bon il y a une
bonne chose dans la loi puisqu'on abroge
l'article 1er de la loi de Vichi de 1940
parce que sans cela rien n'était
possible ceci étant vous avez dit que
vous on rediscute avec six syndicats des
l'organisation du travail très bien vous
avez dit que les employés qui étaient à
statut on les conserve c'est parfait je
pense que c'est c'est toujours comme ça
maintenant pour les nouveaux est-ce que
on va traiter d'un régime social d'un
régime différent de protection sociale
et de retraite parce que c'est là que
les coûts sont plus importants à côté de
l'organisation du
travail et donc j'aurais voulu savoir
sans être comment dire sans que vous
dévoiliez toutes les discussions qui se
fait si on va dans cette direction ou
pas puis j'ai une dernière question qui
qui amuse tout le monde c'est la largeur
des caisses sauf que
oui monsieur sauf que et comme j'ai
discuté avec laadb Ben je vais vous dire
le point de vue de la DB c'est que la
SNCF a bien fait de faire ça parce
qu'elle homologue à matériel elle a
partout le même matériel et la
maintenance coûte beaucoup moins cher
parce qu'en Allemagne il y a des
matériels différents suivant les régions
et les trains qui roulent à munique
peuvent pas aller àovre je ferme la
parenthèse merci de bien vouloir me
répondre merci alors madame Hélène
maassonmaret monsieur le
Président oui mes collègues éid
spécialistes ont déjà pris la parole et
c'est toujours difficile de parler après
eux puisqu'ils ont pratiquement évoqué
tous les sujets mais je voudrais revenir
sur deux choses je ne reviendrai pas sur
la dette abysal parce qu'effectivement
combler quelques pourcentages n'a rien à
voir avec combler les milliards d'euros
mais ça ça a déjà été dit je voudrais
revenir sur le problème qui a surgi au
moment où on a parlé des des
qu enfin du problème de rabotter lesqu à
ce moment-là on a vu surgir la grogne
des régions et c'est là je voudrais
vraiment revenir je crois que c'est un
problème très important pour nous c'est
surtout élus territoriaux alors euh où
est le problème vraiment nous avons déjà
le président de l'Association des
Régions françaises Alain Rousset qui a
une phrase très jolie mais qui veut bien
dire la grogne c'est-à-dire il a dit les
régions ne sont pas des pigeons et il a
tout de suite dit je refuse de payer le
problème de du paiement a été résolu
donc ce n'est pas là-dessus que je vais
revenir mais là-dessus une nouvelle
l'association s'est créée et cette
association elle est donc c'est
Jean-Jacques kerane qui en a pris la
tête c'est une association qui a pour
nom une association d'études sur le
matériel roulant et elle a évidemment
pour but de reprendre pour les
collectivité la main sur les équipements
qu'elle finance mais géré par l'
SNCF donc ma question va être double
comment voyez-vous en tant que président
les futures relations comment
pouvez-vous les améliorer pour qu'il y
ait éventuellement un partenariat plus
intéressant avec les régions pour
qu'elles ne se sentent pas frustré alors
qu'elles sont celles qui payent mais qui
n'ont pas la main sur la gestion qu'ell
ne trouvve pas assez transparente
comment voyez-vous une amélioration et
ma deuxième question est un peu plus
vaste mais j'aimerais avir votre
sentiment là-dessus il y a actuellement
deux réformes en cours une réforme sur
la sur les territoires sur un
élargissement des régions et la réforme
ferroviaire pour vous si ces deux
réformes sont menées est-ce que vous
voyez là une amélioration possible et
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous en pensez
ou est-ce que c'est un nouveau casse-etê
qui va se poser
merci monsieur Jean-Jacques filleel
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
je veux dire d'emblé que je j'approuve
cette réforme je crois qu'il faut il
faut quand même dire les les choses
comme on les pense voilà je pense que le
un système intégré du ferroviaire me
paraît
aujourd'hui me paraissait depuis
longtemps mais voilà on est dedans et
c'est plutôt une bonne chose et puis
j'ai pas peur de dire aussi que votre
discours d'entrée monsieur le
Président dans lequel vous en fait vous
préparez à positiver dans votre
organisation
SNCF l'après
euh système intégré si je puis dire
paraî aussi positif pour que la SNCF
soit en ordre de marche par rapport à
cette réforme en même temps il y a des
questions évidemment qui se qui se pose
et nous avons évidemment regardé le
débat en cours à l'Assemblée nationale
etbre de questions qui vont venir chez
nous aussi au Sénat et j'aimerais bien
que vous puissiez nous nous éclairer de
votre point de vue en
particulier on la mise en conformeté des
règlements OSP
il est clair qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
contradiction très importante et et vous
avez vous-même rappelé que les 10
milliards de chiffres d'affaires hors de
France ce sont des atouts essentiels
pour développer une industrie
ferroviaire dans le monde et la SNCF
doit être le Fire de lance de cette
industrie nous sommes bien d'accord mais
cette réciprocité ça devient un petit
peu lourd actuellement je pense que le
climat le le climat est un peu complexe
le manque de réciprocité évidemment hein
est un crée je crois des choses qui qui
va falloir là aussi éclairer assez
rapidement vous avez évoqué le problème
des AOT régionales mais pour en avoir
débattu encore récemment avec avec le
rapporteur à l'Assemblée nationale il
semble qu'il faille qu'il faut éclairer
ce que c'est que vraiment une autorité
régionale de plein exercice il y a des
questions qui se posent et avant le
débat au Sénat j'aimerais bien qu'on
puisse avoir votre votre avis sur sur
cette affaire là je suis totalement
d'accord avec votre point de vue de
réunification du
foncier c'est un indispensable vous
l'avez dit je répète pas mais je me pose
la question est-ce que dans la future
organisation ne faudrait-il pas affecter
le foncier comme une compétence de l'qu
de de l'épique de
tête et et quel type de compétence vous
voyez dans les pics de tête en règl
général moi je verais bien un certain
nombre de compétences pour que ce soit
un
outil comment dirais-je intéressant quoi
qui joue un rôle dans un certain nombre
de de de d'éléments du du système
intégré en particulier pourquoi pas des
des services communs bon moi j'aimerais
avoir votre
votre point de vue identique pour la
liberté tarifaire on sait que les
régions sont sur ce sur ce
débat c'est une question qui vient et
sur laquelle il va falloir qu'on qu'on
qu'on avance ou qu'on cale nos
réflexions deux derniers points vous
avez rappelé que vous voulez limiter les
LGV les
TGV ok libérer plus les TER évidemment
très important mais quid des tot nous
avons l'impression qu'il y a peut-être
un freinage y compris de l'État sur les
Tet et peut-être des une vision comment
dirais-je à éclairer
sur un certain nombre de lignes Tet qui
seraiit prioritaire par rapport à
d'autres voilà donc là encore c'est
important de que l'on puisse avoir votre
éclairage puis la la question a été
posée mais je me prive pas de revenir
dessus sur les gares il y a vraiment en
particulier sur les gares importantes
celles qui jouent un rôle y compris
commercial dans la
ville bon entre SNCF mobilité SNCF
réseau voilà on a avant ce débat au
Sénat j'ai personnellement quelques
interrogations et j'aimerais bien avoir
votre point de vue merci Monsieur Madame
éeline Didier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le Président Pépi
vous nous avez dit que bien expliquer la
différence entre votre rôle et celui du
ministre nous avons bien entendu nous
serons poser les questions qu'il faut à
monsieur le ministre mais tout de même
vous n'êtes pas pour rien dans dans dans
ce qui est sorti de du des travaux du
gouvernement je veux dire que vous avez
été un partenaire privilégié il ne faut
pas que vous soyez si modeste
euh quand on parle du système
intégré le système intégré vous savez
que pour nous c'est quelque chose
d'important et nous aurions souhaité
qu'on revienne à un système totalement
intégré et pour mesurer du du la réalité
et la véracité de de l'intégration
peut-être pourriez-vous nous nous donner
votre sentiment sur les compétences que
seront les compétences de l'pic de tête
dans la mesure où c'est ça qui en fait
va nous permettre de mesurer le niveau
d'intégration la troisième chose c'est
l'utilisation du réseau euh nous depuis
que je suis au Sénat à la commission des
affaires économiques nous avons entendu
parler de de de la qualité du réseau et
de la régénération nécessaire du réseau
c'est une question récurrente et donc je
crois que de ce point de vue aucun
gouvernement et donc aucun groupe
politique ne peut reprocher à l'autre en
tout cas pour les partis qui ont été au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir fait le
nécessaire je crois que c'est une
responsabilité véritablement collective
euh pouvez-vous nous indiquer euh à
votre avis combien de temps peut-être
aussi combien d'argent mais combien de
temps faudra-t-il pour que le réseau
soit à peu près à niveau dans combien de
temps peut-on sortir raisonnablement de
de cette situation parce
qu'effectivement je pense que tant qu'on
aura pas fait ça le développement le
l'utilisation des sillons toutes ces
questions ne pourront pas être traité
convenablement vous avez à un moment
donné évoqué une
la question des des laissés des des
propriétaires des propriétés et cetera
et vous avez indiqué que celui qui
décide payer vous prêchez totalement une
convaincu nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler sur d'autres
sujets merci
oui je pense que je vais m'arrêter là je
vais faire comme Michel je va je vais en
laisser pour mes collègues
merci alors Monsieur Charles Revet
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président pi vous avez en préambule
indiqué que vous étiez là en tant
qu'opérateur et que vous ne
n'interveniez pas dans le projet de loi
qui de réforme for ferroviaire qui qui
nous est soumis
euh je m'interroge honnêtement bon comme
vient de le dire Eveline Didier je
suppose que vous avez déjà donné votre
avis au ministre et que euh notre
rapporteur a eu l'occasion de vous
écouter moi je je vous êtes ici devant
la
commission qui va établir le
texte qui sera soumis à l'assemblée
c'est pas le texte le projet du
gouvernement c'est le projet qui sortira
de notre commission alors comment
voulez-vous j'ai été le rapporteur des
grands ports portuaires j'ai reçu tous
les grands les présidents et et
directeur généraux de por autonome si
vous qui êtes l'acteur principal nous
dites pas s'il y a dans le texte qui est
présenté des points qui vous préoccupent
comment voulez-vous qu'on le sache donc
quelque part non seulement il y a le
rapporteur
mais mais il y a l'ensemble de la
commission donc me semble-t-il non
seulement il ne serait pas gênant mais
il serait normal et utile si il y a des
éléments qui qui vous préoccupe de nous
le dire c'est à nous après de juger
comment éventuellement on l'intègre ou
pas mais enfin ça c'est une réflexion de
principe hein je bon alors je vais en
venir maintenant puisque vous êtes
l'opérateur et je vais participer un peu
aux mêmes questions qui ont été posés il
y a un instant bon on connaît la
situation de tout à la fois de réseau
ferroviaire et autres il y a eu l'étude
de l'École polytechnique de Lausanne il
y a eu le rapport de la la chambre de la
Cour des comptes
ici honnêtement qui était quand même
très très très
préoccupant or à un moment où tout le
monde s'accorde à dire qu'il faut
redonner au ferroviair une vraie place
qu'il faut le développer et je vais vous
poser une question dans un instant
concernant le transport fret qui me
préoccupe en tant que responsable des
ports ici au au Sénat
euh moi je souhaiterais la question vous
a déjà été un peu posée
existe-t-il dans avec en partenariat
avec RFF vous vous travaillez en
partenariat vous l'avez d'ailleurs cité
et je crois que c'est utile mais
existe-t-il un bilan un état des lieux
précis de la situation et une projection
de ce qu'il faudrait
faire en terme de coût et en terme de
délai pour que véritablement le réseau
fer dont on a été et le système
ferroviaire dont on a été fier durant
très longues années retrouve sa place
puisque c'est un objectif pardelà nos
idées politiques que l'on partage tous
en commun en disant qu'il faut le
développer et alors est-ce que ça existe
c'est le premier point la deuxième
question c'est cuide il existe à peu
près 10000 km de voie ferré secondaires
qui sont inutilisé vous l'avez abordé
tout à l'heure ce qui nous préoccupe
c'est pas c'est d'abord l'entretien bien
sûr mais c'est aussi peut-on envisager
puisqu'on veut développer le transport
collectif de réactivé y compris vous
l'avez cité vous savez que je suis un
amateur la mise en place du tramtain
puisqu'on a un réseau ferroviaire
extraordinaire en France peut-être l'un
des meilleurs qui existe qui a été conçu
par nos aînés nos ancêtres hein on se
demande comment ils onont pu le faire
alors qu'on narrive pas à avancer
aujourd'hui et c'est pas le président de
la commission qui dénonce sa situation
dans ce département souvent qui peut me
dire le contraire cuide est-ce que dans
les perspectives euh c'est peut-être pas
demain mais c'est après-demain on peut
envisager une réactivation d'un certain
nombre de lignes y compris sous forme de
de tramtin et ma dernière pour pas aller
trop loin mais j'en viens au au au port
vous savez que la part SNCF de la part
ferroviaire du frite elle
est presque rien aujourd'hui presque
rien soyons clair orors tout le monde
souhaite que ça augmente non seulement à
l'intérieur mais surtout sur les longues
distances on a la chance d'avoir en
France les deux plus grands ports
européens a priori qui sont Marsaille
d'un côté et le HAV que je connais un
peu mieux chez nous à partir du on
devrait pouvoir aller jusqu'en Europe
centrale or pour l'instant ça ne se fait
pas ou pratiquement pas y a-t-il une
possibilité d'examiner la situation
précise je l'ai dit au ministre hier
hein puisqu'on avait deux fois moi j'ai
fait une question hier matin sur la
scène maritime et et hier après-midi on
a examiner ça et j' en ai parlé peut-on
imaginer quand même qu'on regarde les
choses un peu près que nous soyons
associés parce que même si nous sommes
pas exécutif nous sommes quand même
intéressés par ce qui va se passer à à à
l'examen d'une comment dirais-je de
d'un d'un parcours qui permettrait
d'aboutir à
s ces objectifs parce que ça me paraît
tout à fait essentiel et dernier point
peut-être pouvez-vous nous expliquer ce
que vous avez affirmé qui P décide
qu'est-ce que vous sous-entendez par là
par rapport notamment aux régions qui
interviennent beaucoup et jusqu'où
éventuellement il pourrait y avoir une
évolution merci Monsieur Alain houè et
ensuite Monsieur Roland R pour la
dernière
question
monsieur monsieur le président
je ne suis pas un spécialiste du
ferroviaire comme Monsieur ou
monsieur grillon grriillon je j'ai parlé
en tant que que usager de de la SNCF on
a parlé tout à l'heure de la dette qui
est àissale mais je pense que la dette
vient aussi d'un système social qui a
été très généreux et différent du
système social général donc je pense que
dans les réformes les réformes ça veut
dire un peu révolution il faut pour
faire une réforme en
profondeur je pense que j'ai cru savoir
que dans vos actifs dans
vos dans dans vos collaborateurs il y a
il y a moins d'actifs que de retraités
donc je pense que votre dette est quand
même en
partie dans dans ce chapitre et les
investissements automatiquement en
souffre et nous avons besoin
d'investissement nous
verons fait des élections européennes il
y a pas très longtemps et je pense que
l'Europe a besoin d'une harmonisation
dans T dans tous les secteurs et en
particulier dans le système ferroviaire
et je pense que on fait des réformes
toujours
franco-françaises dans chaque pays mais
je pense qu'il faudrait un grand plan
européen
ferroviaire pour harmoniser parce que
voyager en Europe avec un train c'est
quand même difficile malheureusement
c'est plus plus facile en
avion
euh
je le train pour moi ça doit être un
moyen de déplacement
populaire et je
constate que le train coûte
cher et pour un Français moyen quelqu'un
qui vient de la classe moyenne se
déplacer si c'est pas son entreprise qui
paye le déplacement se déplacer en
famille c'est quand même très cher et il
faut être
ingénieux consulter
internet prévoir à l'avance pour avoir
des des prix défiant en toute
concurrence donc c'est vraiment un
parcours du combattant pour se déplacer
ce n'est pas que mon avis hein en tant
que sénateur les gens nous disent
régulièrement que le train coûte cher et
quand c'est c'est souvent plus facile et
ça coûte souvent moins cher de partir de
la province à Paris en voiture et ça
c'est dommage je pense que le le train
est un outil de développement durable
pour faire en sorte que notre planète
soit plus propre et plus belle bon il y
a eu ce fameux bug sur le rabotage des
traits des trains je pense qu'il faut
vraiment c'est une illustration du
bordel permanent
quoi il faudra qu'on arrive
à communiquer entre les régions entre la
SNCF vous allez faire un épic de tête
c'est très bien mais ce qui serait mieux
ça serait de rassembler RFF
et et la SNCF il y a aussi
Alstom ça ne vous concerne pas mais je
pense que le capital d'Alstom qui va
partir à l'étranger je pense que c'est
un drame
franco-français parce que la vitrine de
la France a quand même été les TGV qui
ont été initié lancé sous François sous
monsieur Pompidou Gil cardestin inauguré
par par François milteran mais cette
vitrine elle se dégrade fortement quand
on monte dans le TGV on voit des quand
même du matériel roulant qui est très
très vieux et les gens qui se déplacent
en train maintenant euh le temps est
compté sont des gens qui travaillent
dans le train et l'accès aux nouvelles
technologies dans les
trains moi j'ai la chance de voir des
trains italiens qui qui passe à
Dijon on est heureux parce qu'il y a
tout ça marche bien il faudrait aussi
travailler avec les opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile je sais que vous avez
un contrat avec
SFR quand on n pas la chance d'être sur
SFR c'est très difficile de se pas de
téléphoner parce que c'est interdit mais
d'envoyer des CNCF des des des SMS et le
lapsus est révélateur des SMS et
d'envoyer des mails coup à notre iPad ou
notre ordinateur je pense que le TGV a
été une vitrine du progrès français il
faudrait mettre une part
d'investissement justement sur sur ce ce
travail avec les opérateurs pour que il
y ait au moins une mutualisation ce
qu'on appelle l'itinérance sur vos
pilones SNCF SFR que vous mettiez
l'itinérance c'est-à-dire que obliger
votre programmateur votre SFR à relayer
les deux autres opérateurs euh qu'est-ce
que je voulais dire oui vous n'avez rien
à voir avec
RFF mais nous en tant que élus proche
des élus locaux on a vraiment beaucoup
de demande de et cette dichotomie
entre le G gestionnaire de réseau et
l'utilisateur de réseau est
complètement absurde parce que
régulièrement moi j'ai des maires qui
sont traversés par une voie ferrée et
qui ont un pont qui passe sur une petite
ligne et c'est une voie communale et ça
fait des années qu'ils essayent de
pouvoir rénover cette voie communale
mais le pont appartient à rfff en
particulier j'ai un si vous pouvez en
parler à Monsieur roport J'ai un village
qui s'appelle poinçon les Daret où il y
a une un train qui se passe par jour et
ce MRE ça fait 20 ans qu'il essae de
réouvrir cette voie communale et ces
habitants sont obligés de faire 20 km
pour aller euh c'est un peu comme la
traversée du RIN quoi voilà il y a des
reins partout en France qui sont des
lignes de chemin de fer de petites
capacités et je pense que ça serait
faire du bien caresser l'âme des
citoyens français que on puisse
justement grâce à cet épique de tête
faire en sorte que le bon sens régnonne
sur notre sur
notre sur notre France oui et l'Europe
l'Europe elle est là pour faire pour
créer des géants de l'industrie des
géants de l'industrie donc il faut
travailler vraiment pour qu'il y ait un
programme ferroviaire européen et là on
sortira par le haut merci merci Monsieur
Roland ris
oui merci beaucoup monsieur les
présidents euh
d'abord dire à mon collègue que le
passage du rein aujourd'hui ça pose pas
trop de problème on a pas mal progresser
par rapport à une certaine époque on a
de nombreux
pots bon je voudrais beaucoup de choses
ont été ditite mais je voudrais ajouter
deux ou trois points qui me tiennent à
cœur le
premier c'est que moi je m'adresse au
président de d'une société qui est
évidemment société pas comme les autres
la SNCF qui est opérateur de transport
ferroviaire et donc je comprends et
j'approuve les prudences de Guillaume
péi euh pour ne pas mélanger les les
genres moi je suis très attaché à la
distinction entre autorité organisatrice
et opérateurs de transport c'est pas la
même chose c'est pas les mêmes fonction
et euh
euh pour ce qui concerne le transport
urbain cela fait très longtemps
maintenant que on fait cette distinction
même si l'opérateur peut éclairer les
choix de l'autorité organisatrice c'est
pas à lui de les les les faire c'est
important de de de de rappeler cela
parce que
euh on a trop longtemps
vécu sur la base d'une SNCF État dans
l'État à la fois autorité organisatrice
et opérateur or cette cette situation
qui qui a duré très longtemps
aujourd'hui elle ne peut elle ne peut
pas elle ne doit pas durer et je pense
que un des objectifs de la réforme
ferroviaire c'est bien d'aller dans ce
sens-là et moi j'approuve globalement ce
projet de loi parce que je pense que il
est indispensable de faire
évoluer à la fois la conception que nous
avons de l'autorité atrice ferroviaire
et de de
l'opérateur ça c'est la première chose
que que que je voulais dire la
deuxième c'est les aspects politiques de
tout cela je parle pas de politique
politicienne je parle de politique
ferroviaire moi je pense
que il y a un modèle qui fonctionne
depuis longtemps et qui fonctionne
plutôt bien en France je regarde pas
trop trop vers vers l'étranger même si
on peut tirer des leçons de ce qui se
passe en Allemagne ou
ailleurs ce modèle c'est le modèle de la
DSP délégation de service public qui
fonctionne dans le transport urbain et
qui consiste pour l'autorité
organisatrice à définir un cahier des
charges à dire ce qu'on veut queles sont
les stratégies quels sont les objectifs
qu'on se fixe et comme ça quels sont les
moyens qu'on se donne pour les pour les
atteindre et ensuite et bien il y a une
concurrence régulée concurrence régulée
pas une concurrence sauvage sur la base
du cahier des charges avec la
possibilité pour les autorités
organisatrices de choisir soit la régie
elle elles font en direct les choses
c'est possible ça existe dans un certain
nombre de de villes françaises pas trop
nombreuses mais il y en a soit la
délégation de service public a une
société d'économie mixte soit la
délégation de service public à une
société privée c'est c'est ouvert et ça
fonctionne comme ça depuis euh euh
depuis les années 80 avec donc une
liberté laissée aux uns et aux autres
alors le modèle n'est pas transposable
tel quel naturellement euh parce que le
système ferroviaire est euh non
seulement est national mais il est
international et évidemment on ne peut
pas séparer les euh les secteurs et dire
bah là on fait comme ça et là on fait
autrement on peut le faire mais il faut
qu'il y ait une régulation qui se qui se
fasse par ailleurs donc je je moi je
suis favorable je un socialdémocrate
invétéré comme ça depuis toujours j'ai
pas changer moi euh c'est-à-dire que je
suis bah il y en a d'autres euh mais pas
qui donnez pas
qui non non non
non je ne me laisserai pas entraîner
dans ces voies non
ferroviaires je je pense que le la
concurrence et le marché a son
importance comme moteur du développement
mais le marché est aveugle et il faut le
réguler il faut le réguler je suis pour
une concurrence régulé comme nous le
faisons dans les autorités
organisatrices urbaines tout le monde ne
sera pas d'accord encore ici mais c'est
mon point de vue et je le défendrai y
compris dans le débat parlementaire ça
c'est pour les aspects politiques 2è
élément 3è les régions les autorités
organisatrices régionales
elle n'existe pas aujourd'hui elle
n'existe pas en tout cas elle n'existe
pas sous la forme accomplie qui devrait
être la leure et c'est qu'on qu'on fasse
des grandes régions ou des petites
régions ne change rien euh pour qu'il y
ait autorité organisatrice il faut qu'il
y ait un un une compétence clairement
identifiée
entre la Région et l'État et de qu'il y
ait une recette une ressource dédiée on
en a pas on a peut parler mais s'il en a
pas la ressource si la région les
régions n'ont pas les ressources ce sont
des des
paralytique des impuissants
où ell puiss ont sur leur budget normal
pour essayer de faire le moins mal
possible mais on arrive aux limite de ce
système aujourd'hui si on y arrive pas
alors ça peut être le VT interstitiel ou
additionnel à voir ou ça peut être autre
chose 4èe élément la
dette moi je pense que l'objectif de
stabilisation de la dette il est
indispensable mais il faut qu'il se
fasse sur une base simple et claire
monsieur le même si c'est pas
directement de votre compétence cette
base c'est que on ne n'investi qu'à la
condition que l'investissement soit
adossé à des recettes
prévisionnelles on ninvestit
pas pour augmenter la dette pour laisser
filer la la dette dont on sait déjà plus
aujourd'hui comment la comment la gère
donc notamment pour les TGV et bien ou
pour la la restructuration
l'amélioration la modernisation du du
réseau les deux étant évidemment à à
mettre en parallèle il faut avoir des
recettes dédiées des des perspectives de
de d'amortissement de de de ces
investissement sinon on laissera on
continuera à laisser filer la dette et
enfin il y a un dernier sujet qui me
tient à cœur c'est la question du fret
ferroviaire là aussi on est dans une
situation extrêmement difficile pourquoi
parce que on est dans une concurrence
non régulé entre la route et et le
ferroviaire et le l'éco
redevance va dans ce sens elle elle est
destinée à internaliser dans les coûtes
du de de la route les frais
d'infrastructure qui sont internalisés
dans dans le ferroviaire et donc la
concurrence est est faussée de ce point
de vue il faut absolument que cette
échoredevance on puisse la mettre en
place il y avait un consensus politique
là-dessus il s'est un peu effiloché au
fil du temps il faut le le retrouver
c'est indispensable sinon non seulement
on aura le problème du fret mais on aura
aussi le problème des de l'appel à à
projet les 450 millions dont on sait pas
aujourd'hui comment on les les financera
voilà alors ce sont des questions sans
être vraiment des questions monsieur le
Président mais euh si vous pouviez
peut-être répondre
à mes collègues l'ont l'ont fait à à ces
questions sensibles euh
la dimension politique même si c'est pas
votre rôle peut-être en direct la dette
les régions et le fret merci alors
dernière question madame anne-emarie
Escoffier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président vraiment deux questions
très très courtes parce que je m'associe
toutes les questions déjà posées et sur
lesquelles vous apporterez des réponses
je m'interroger simplement sur le
patrimoine de la SNCF qui est
considérable vous avez parlé du problèm
des fonciers des projets bloqués et
cetera mais il y a aussi un problème de
de foncier que SNCF serait susceptible
de vendre donc de faire rentrer dans ses
actifs et je j'aurais aimé savoir un
petit peu avoir un peu la une
connaissance de l'ensemble de vos
projets sur ce sur ce sujet-là deuxième
question aussi très très courte on on a
parlé du transport ferroviaire voyageurs
et frite euh on n pas parlé de l'avion
on a un peu peut parler des routes
j'aurais voulu savoir comment au niveau
national en terme d'aménagement du
territoire on met en cohérence
l'ensemble de ces moyens de transport
voilà trois questions deux questions
courtes merci Monsieur Merci alors
Monsieur Jean-Pierre bosin pas vous
priver de poser la dernière question
merci monsieur le Président
oui très très court aussi puisque
beaucoup de choses on ont été dites
mais j'aurais aimé savoir si on avait
une évaluation du mur de travaux dont
nous parlait le président Pépi tout à
l'heure
et comment on
gère cette contradiction entre un mur de
travaux enfin qui m'apparaît comme une
contradiction considérable et puis cette
volonté de réaliser toujours des
économies
sur sur les investissement et la gestion
du du du
réseau première question deè question
est-ce que puisqueon on parle beaucoup
de faire des économies est-ce qu'il y a
une réflexion est-ce qu'il y a eu une
réflexion sur la
possibilité de faire grandir les
recettes parce que pour réduire une
dette il y a évidemment la possibilité
de faire des économies mais il a aussi
possibilité de faire grandir des
recettes est-ce qu'il y a une réflexion
tout en préservant les usagers des
transports
évidemment quelle possibilité de faire
grand
grandir les recettes et puis dernière
question elle concerne les
personnels on a entendu le la question
du du statut donc les les
cheminaux sous statut actuel restent
sous statut et puis en même temps on
négocie une convention collective qui
concernera 100 % des
agents quel sera le statut des nouveaux
embauchés de la de la
SNCF pour la suite parce qu'évidemment
euh bon ça ça a déjà été posé mais c'est
une question importante hein une
question sociale et puis du coup dans la
foulée euh ça m'amène à cette ce dernier
mot euh cuit de l'égalité de traitement
sur l'ensemble du territoire parce que
on parle d' de d'autorité organis
organisatrices des transports mais du
coup ça pose quand même la question de
l'égalité de traitement sur l'ensemble
du territoire pour le service public de
transport ferroviaire
très
bien je pas dire en deux mots allez en
tris bien bon d'abord merci beaucoup
parce que je trouve qu'on a si vous me
permettez une réaction personnelle je
pense qu'on a fait un tour d'horizon
assez complet de toutes les questions de
court moyen long terme qui sont appelés
par le sujet donc je vous prie d'excuser
par avance le caractère un peu lapidaire
des réponses parce que euh évidemment
chacune d'entre elles pourrait mériter
un débat assez approfondi sur les
tenants et et les aboutissants je vais
essayer de de de reprendre les questions
de chaque interlocuteur parce que sinon
je pense qu'on va on va en oublier mais
être très bref à chaque fois Monsieur
Teston a posé quatre questions d'abord
la gestion par activité qui est de en
vigueur la SNCF depuis 1991 donc depuis
maintenant une vingtaine d'années euh ne
crée-elle pas des rigidités elle se s
elle s'est substituée à une gestion par
circonscription géographique on va dire
par presque par canton oui c'est un
risque vous avez raison mais en même
temps je veux donner aux sénateurs un
exemple moi j'ai connu la SNCF à
l'époque où il n'y avait pas la gestion
par activité ça se passait comment et
bien c'est très simple toutes les
ressources quelle qu'elle soit allait
prioritairement au voyageurs et le fret
était la dernière rou du carrosse et la
variable d'ajustement un pépin sur un
train régional bah on prend le
conducteur du train de frite le résultat
c'est que l'activité frite avait une
qualité de service honteuse et
aujourd'hui j'assume le fait qu'un
conducteur du
fret ne peut pas sauf cas on va dire de
bon sens être entre guillemets
prélevé par l'activité TGV ou l'activité
TER parce que si ça se trouve ce qui est
derrière c'est pour le client frit pour
le chargeur c'est le choix modal he si
on rate plus de une ou deux fois par
mois ou par an ce transport de fret et
bien ça passera la route parce que
l'industrielle ne peut pas le supporter
donc je je partage avec Monsieur Teston
le fait que c'est une ex compliqué hein
et qu'il faut du bon sens il faut un peu
de pragmatisme mais on ne sauvera le
fret qu'avec des moyens dédiés et de la
même façon on parlait des autorités
organisatrices chacun des présidents de
Région veut savoir quels sont les moyens
effectivement mis en œuvre par la SNCF
pour rendre le service public de tel
sorte qu'il puisse apprécier d'abord la
transparence financière savoir s'il
n'est pas grugé dans cette affaire là et
puis qu'il puisse aussi se faire une
opinion disant le crument sur le rapport
coût efficacité des moyens qu'on y met
donc oui gestion par activité en même
temps faut pas être doctrinaire deuxème
point
Intercité c'est bien je trouve c'est
intéressant que vous soulevie ce sujet
il y a une vaste mise à plat à faire
puisque le premier contrat vient à
échéance le 31 décembre
2014 nous avons commencé cette mise à
plat et pour moi la piste la plus
prometteuse c'est celle de la commission
mobilité 21 qui recommande la création
d'une activité en quelque sorte de train
rapide de grandes ligne en
France comme il en existe en Allemagne
des des trains qui roulent à 160 200 ou
220 qui sont rapides et qui en même
temps ne supposent pas l'investissement
des lignes à grande vitesse c'est la
recommandation principale du rapport moi
je la crois très porteuse pour l'avenir
des Intercités qui aujourd'hui se
définissent par ni TER ni TGV ce qui est
pas terrible il vaut mieux que le Nini
il vaut mieux créer une vraie activité
qui correspond à un besoin d'aménagement
du territoire vous avez rappelé le mot
3è question sur les
régions il y a eu une crise et j'ai dit
y compris au Sénat que dans cette crise
les régions avaient largement
raison nous sommes en train de sortir de
cette
crise trois exemples premier exemple les
contentieux financiers sont quasiment
tous réglés il n'y a plus de suspension
de paiement et nous avons signer des
avenant dont la caractéristique est que
en 2015 voire même en 2014 le
devis sera stable à offre constante
c'était la demande des régions pour la
raison qu'a indiqué Roland ris pas de
recette nouvelle et c'est ça les avenant
que nous sommes en train de signer et
donc je ne dis pas que tout est Ros sur
le plan financier mais le message des
raisons des régions est entendu et on
travaille à faire des économies sans
réduire le service public deuxième
exemple j'ai proposé au congrès de l'ARF
qui s'est tenu à Nantes l'automne
dernier j'ai proposé au nom de la SNCF
opérateur trois choses liberté tarifaire
j'ai proposé propriété régionale des
matériels j'ai proposé gouvernance
régionale des
gares c'est une proposition qui émane de
l'opérateur mais c'est un débat
politique qui revient au gouvernement et
au Parlement de trancher et enfin le
troisième exemple de cette sortie de
crise c'est le fait que
je suis favorable à ce que les comptes
TER de laasncf soi soit certifiés ce qui
est une façon pour comme pour tous les
les activités d'avoir la certitude qu'il
n'y a pas de surpaiement soit qu'il soit
validé par la RAF ce qui est une des
propositions qui est dans les
amendements qui vous seront soumis en
tout cas moi je suis favorable à ce que
les régions soient sûr et certaines
qu'elles ne sont en aucune manière sur
entre chargé de paiement qu'elle ne
devrait pas faire 4è
sujet le sujet de la
grève la réforme qui est proposée
aujourd'hui elle fait l'objet d'un très
vaste consensus politique au moins sur
sa nécessité et sur son
principe ça c'est un point très
important il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de groupe qui contestent
l'utilité d'une réforme son contenu
maintenant je comprends que et le
gouvernement par la voie de Fréd huviler
et votre commission et celle de
l'Assemblée ont examiné voir adopté des
très nombreux amendements ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire la porte est
ouverte il y a une marge de manœuvre
pour la
discussion et donc je me permets de de
dire que deux organisations indical sur
4 lance dès aujourd'hui un préavis de
grève me paraît un peu prématuré
peut-être un peu
précipité surtout si l'on prend en
compte le fait que le ministre des
Transports a
annoncé il y a quelques jours qu'il
recevrait
l'intersyndicale le jeudi 12 à
15h et donc entre l'apport du travail
des commissions et l'apport du travail
de Parlement d'une part entre le
rendez-vous que les organisations
syndicales ont avec le gouvernement et
le ministre chargé des transports il me
semble qu'il y a place pour une
discussion
utile
nécessaire j'observe enfin que il y a
deux organisations syndicales qui ont
déposé ce préavis il y a deux autres
organisations syndical qui n'ont pas
déposé de préavis et par conséquent il
faut me semble-t-il que moi je m prime
comme responsable de cette entreprise
souligner et l'existence d'un préavis et
l'existence aussi d'organisation
sindicales qui ne se sont pas jointes au
préavis enfin je signale parce que je
pense que les cheminau savent faire
preuve de
responsabilité que le lundi
16 600000 lycéens passent le
baccalauréat et que le
baccalauréat c'est le résultat de
plusieurs années de travail pour les
600000 lycéens et les lycéens comptent
sur le service public et il faudra que
le service public soit au rendez-vous le
lundi 16 car personne ne peut imaginer
que 600000 familles puissent être
perturbées par une un mouvement social
pour lesquels les familles considérées
n'ont que peu de marge de manœuvre pour
moins qu'on puisse dire donc voilà
maintenant la discussion est engagée la
discussion continue le ministre les
reçoit il y a un débat parleement ire il
me semble que toutes les garanties
d'ouverture sont aujourd'hui sur la
table question de Monsieur Louis negre
l'ARAF j'ai mentionné il y a quelques
instants le fait que comme
opérateur nous souhaitons un régulateur
fort maintenant le réglage des
compétences du régulateur
ou de l'administration ça c'est vraiment
une question politique il faut en tout
cas un régulateur fort un régulateur qui
est juridique et
économique je reviendrai sur la dette
dans un instant sur la place des élus et
et des usagers dans la proposition de
Frédérique
cuvilier mon opinion c'est que on a
jusqu'à présent pas assez pris
conscience de ce qu'est le Conseil
surveillance du du ferroviaire qui est
proposé par le projet c'est une novation
considérable si je force un tout petit
peu le trait aujourd'hui Jacques
Rapoport et moi nous présidons
nous-mêmes nos conseils d'administration
c'est une particularité française c'est
l'exécutif qui préside lui-même le
conseil d'administration de l'entreprise
alors il y a la tutelle mais ENF c'est
pas la même chose la proposition qui est
fait dans le projet c'est le système
allemand il y a des gens qui gèent et il
y a des gens qui contrôle et bien cette
proposition là qui n'était pas la nôtre
mais que le gouvernement vous propose
elle me paraît être un progrès
considérable le président du conseil de
surveillance qui sera nommé aura donc
deux responsabilités lourdes
premièrement de recevoir très
périodiquement le rapport et de discuter
du rapport devant le conseil de
surveillance des du directoire et en
Allemagne j'indique que ça dure une
demi-journée tous les de mois où les
dirigeants sont passés au grill du
conseil de surveillance et deuxièmement
le conseil de surveillance comme en
Allemagne il définit et mise met en
œuvre une politique ferroviaire du pays
sous le contrôle des autorités
politiques et donc le conseil de
surveillance en Président c'est une
institution fondamentale et à
l'intérieur de laquelle le gouvernement
a dit il y aura les régions il y aura
les représentant des
usagers un petit mot a été dit par
Monsieur sur le Directoire le Directoire
là encore on est dans le système que nos
collègues allems ont choisi qui est
quand même pas si bête que ça il y a
deux entités il y a une entité de réseau
avec un PDG il y a une entité de service
avec un PDG et la proposition du
gouvernement qui vous est faite est de
dire ces deux PDG constituent un
binô pardon un couple qui est
solidairement responsable devant le
conseil de surveillance et le pays de la
bonne marche du système c'est quand même
difficile de faire plus simple et c'est
quand même difficile de faire plus
efficace puisque les deux responsables
seront conjointement responsables du
fonctionnement commun aucun pingpong
aucun jeu tactique une responsabilité
solidaire entre le réseau et le service
sur le bon fonctionnement du service
public enfin sur les
gares c'est une question très débattue
il y a la moitié des pays d'Europe qui
ont mis les gardes du côté du réseau il
y a la moitié des pays d'Europe qui
l'ont mis du côté du service donc il y a
pas de vérité absolue avec Jacques
Rapoport on en a longuement discuté et
notre recommandation puisque monsieur
revet j'assume tout à fait d'avoir fait
des recommandations j'y reviendrai dans
un instant notre recommandation est
plutôt de les laisser du côté du service
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
la réforme est déjà énorme et Jacques
Rapoport le dira devant votre assemblée
ajoutez un volégard avec les 10000
personnes qui travaillent dans les gares
et qui sont des métiers d'accueil des
métiers clientèle les ajouté au réseau
Jacques Rapoport a dit c'est vraiment
charger la barque et la deuxième raison
c'est que je constate de la part des
concurrents actuels et futurs de la SNCF
il y en a quelquesuns aujourd'hui je
constate que le système que vous avez
mis en place vous le Parlement en
2009 vous avez créé une entité à
l'intérieur de la SNCF qui s'appelle
gare et connexion c'est une loi de 2009
ce système là assez
récent n'est contesté par personne et
pas par les concurrents de la SNCF il
n'y a aucune affaire contentieuse devant
la RAF ni devant l'Autorité de la
concurrence donc ma recommandation c'est
de ne pas traiter des problèmes qui ne
se posent pas avec une acité
particulière et donc de conserver gare
et connexion que vous avez créé en 2009
dans l'entreprise de de service en
revanche les cours marchandises euh
question clairire de Monsieur grigon
réponse claire oui elles sont
transférées par le projet je pense avoir
donc dit quelques mots sur les questions
de Monsieur grigon et Monsieur Grignon
insistait aussi sur le
fret et je monsieur que ris hier
estevenenu et plusieurs autres
interlocuteurs je je l'ai noté également
sur le
fret je je veux dire les choses avec
engagement et un peu de passion on n'est
plus il y a 4 ans où Fred SNCF était en
semi faillite on n'est plus là on a
travaillé avec les équipes de fret SNCF
avec les clients avec les organisations
professionnelles on n'est pas totalement
sorti d'affaires mais je veux vous
donner les chiffres en 2008 la marge
opérationnelle est négative de - 380
presque ins 400
million cette année elle sera négative
de l'ordre de 100 à 120 nous avons fait
presque les 3/4 du chemin du retour à
l'équilibre nous avons stabilisé les
volumes depuis l'année
dernière c'est-à-dire que nous avons
recentré Fret SNCF sur les flux qui sont
les flux de long parcours là où on est
compétitif par rapport à la route et
nous avons recentré sur le portuaire
cher à Monsieur revet sur le combiné sur
les autoroutes ferroviaires et sur les
trafics
européens ce niveau est très
bas
incontestable mais mais ça commence à
repartir et cette année nous sommes déjà
en volume à plus 2 % et la vérité c'est
que Fr SNCF regagne des parts de marché
sur ses concurrents
enfin ce qu'on a appelé dans un langage
rapide le plan
borlau de qui date de
2007 200008 qui prévoyait des
investissements et des nouveaux produits
sur le fret ferroviaire ce plan se met
en œuvre les autoroutes ferroviaires le
combiné portuaire le fret européen bref
nous sommes en train d'inventer année
après année un nouveau fret ferroviaire
enfin dernier point la satisfaction des
clients évidemment quand les clients
sont satisfaits ça inéresse personne
comme quand les train arrivent à l'heure
mais c'est aussi mon rôle de dire que
les 9000 cheminau du fret ont fait un
boulot extraordinaire vous vous souvenez
sans doute que en 201 2011 sur 2 ans la
satisfaction des clients a augmenté de
10 points on vient de terminer l'enquête
2012-23 la satisfaction augmenté de 18
points 84 % des chargeurs clients de
fret SNCF sont très satisfaits ou
satisfaits il en reste donc 16 % il sont
pas satisfaits il y a encore du boulot
mais je veux devant le Sénat réaffirmer
que l'engagement des cheminau les
efforts sur eux-mêm les suppression de
postees très nombreuses ont constitué un
effort de restructuration qu'il faut me
semble-t-il aussi saluer et soutenir sur
les
sillons monsieur grigon c'est une menace
réelle
il existe aujourd'hui alors le nom est
horrible un
péage négatif c'est-à-dire une sorte de
subvention publique au frait de
ferroviaire dans notre pays qui
représente 40 % des
sillons 40 % du coût des sillons si ce
phéage négatif venait à disparaître tous
les opérateurs français les 18
opérateurs français devrai
redimensionner leur activité je n'ai pas
d'information
mais si ça devait arriver ça serait une
menace sur le volume du fra de
ferroviaire
français sur le statut le cadre social
harmonisé toujours question de Monsieur
Grignon le projet de loi qui vous est
soumis ne remet pas en cause le statut
des cheminau pour ceux qui ont les
conditions et les conditions sont très
simple moins de 30 ans on est embauché
au statut pour une raison simple c'est
que ça permet de financer le régime de
retraite le régime de retraite est
devenu un régime d'État et il est
financé par les cotisations des cheminau
et les cotisations de l'entreprise plus
une subvention liée au déséquilibre
démographique donc à l'avenir quand on a
moins de 30 ans on est embauché au
statut parce que on permet ainsi de
financer le régime de raite de ceux qui
prennent leur retraite deuxième cas on a
plus de 30 ans on est embauché en
CDI car le statut Chemino est très lié à
ce fameux régime de retraite donc quand
on a plus de 30 ans on est embauché
entre guillemets CDI et régime général
et donc le projet de loi ne comporte pas
de changement sur cette question pour la
raison que j'indique c'est le lien avec
le régime de
retraite deux questions de madame madame
maçon muret première question les
régions qui le souhaitent pourront-elles
acheter directement le matériel c'est la
proposition de cette association
présidée par jean-jaces herad la réponse
est oui est-ce que ça pose un problème à
la SNCF la réponse est non si les
régions souhaitent acheter directement
leur matériel elles appliqueront le code
des marchés publics comme elles le font
sur d'autres achats et elles achèteront
auprès des constructeurs leur matériel
je n'ai aucun état d'âme sur cette
question deuxièmement est-ce que
question très très per enfin je trouve
très euh intéressante est-ce que la
réforme territoriale qui pourrait être
faite influe sur le système ferroviaire
là je m'exprime plutôt comme citoyen
euh si nous avons en France des grandes
régions ça sera un bénéfice très
important pour le système ferroviaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui nos TER sont très
émiettés avec des problèmes que vous
connaissez c'est tous de liaisons entre
régions des parcs qu'on ne peut pas
mutualiser parce que chacun a acheté son
propre parc et une dimension
d'aménagement du territoire qui est qui
est malgré tout très restreinte donc de
grandes régions qui seront des grandes
régions ferroviaires je pense que ça
fera faire de l'efficacité et des
économie par une meilleure mutualisation
et au demeurant je vous indique que avec
Jacques Rapoport
on calera évidemment l'organisation SNCF
sur ces nouvelles régions évidemment et
donc on fera aussi des économies de frit
structure et qui sont nécessaires pour
avoir un service public qui soit
efficace et compétitif sur les questions
de Monsieur
filleul monsieur filleel a soulevé un
point qui est technique et en même temps
d'une très grande importance politique
et je vous en
remercie ça nécessite une phrase ication
au Parlement européen l'autre jour en
février tout s'est bien passé
sauf sauf un vote le Parlement européen
a adopté une espèce de sanction à
l'égard des
pays qui n'ouvriraient pas
progressivement à la concurrence leur
marché d'ici 2019 ou
2023 c'est la clause de réciprocité
c'est en clair si vous n'avez pas ouvert
vos entreprises ne peuvent pas aller
dans les pays qui sont ouverts et donc
cette clause qui est probablement
illégale mais qui a été votée
politiquement consiste à dire que les
Français parce que le marché français ne
comporte pas aujourd'hui de dispositifs
qui préparent l'ouverture les
entreprises françaises ne pourraient
plus s'implanter en Allemagne en Italie
dans dans le domaine ferroviaire alors
encore une fois on espère que qu'elle
est qu'elle est illégale et on espère
queelle ne va pas finalement être mise
en uvre mais si elle est mise en
œuvre le ferroviaire français a des
soucis à se faire parce que ça
signifierait que tout ce que nous avons
gagné comme contrat marché emploi
valorisation de nos savoir-faire serait
remis en cause ailleurs en Europe donc
c'est une alerte extrêmement sérieuse
qui est qui est devant
nous et dans le domaine de
l'urbain si je fais un peu de baching
comme on dit de nos jours un peu de
baching de nos amis allemands dans
l'urbain l'urbain allemand n'est pas
aujourd'hui ouvert ça n'empêche pas les
entreprises allemandes de pouvoir se
présenter en France donc il y a quand
même un
problème enfin deux derniers mots euh
sur l'intervention de Monsieur
filleul les compétences de la tête de
groupe vous allez en débattre hein c'est
un des articles du projet de loi donc je
mentionne simplement ce que le projet
prévoit c'est trois choses
1 la tête de groupe est responsable des
aspects systèm c'est-à-dire de la bonne
intégration entre la voie le rail et le
train et ça c'est au bénéfice pas
seulement de la SNCF mais comme le
disait monsieur Nigre au bénéfice de
toutes les entreprises
ferroviaires et il faudra que ça soit
non discriminatoire et pour reprendre
l'expression il faudra qu'il y ait des
murailles de Chine adéquates
2 le pacte social cheminau est de la
responsabilité de la tête de groupe pour
qu'il y ait une unité sociale du groupe
ce sont des amendements qui ont été déjà
présentés en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui vont dans la bonne
direction l'unité sociale parallèle à
l'unité technique et à l'unité
économique et enfin troisème compétence
ben puisqu'il y a un groupe il y a des
fonctions de de pilotage qui sont
confiés à la tête de groupe je vous ai
cité le foncier euh monsieur filleul
mentionna
est-ce qu'il faut le mettre dans la loi
ça serait bien je pense de mettre cette
compétence foncière dans l'établissement
public de tête tout ça sous le contrôle
de ce fameux conseil de surveillance
mais puisque monsieur revet me me
poussait à la liberté totale de parole
et n'étant donc pas ministre et n'étant
donc pas syndicaliste et n je vous dis
moi personnellement je pense qu'on
pourrait donner aussi une compétence
sécurité à la tête de groupe
brtini ou d'autres accidents
ferroviaires c'est toujours une affaire
d'interaction
entre le mobile et le rail et dans le
respect de
l'indépendance cher à Monsieur ne des
fonctions essentielles et cher à
l'Europe dans ce respect de cette
indépendance il me semble que c'est pas
idiot que le pays sache que les deux
patrons du directoire ont le devoir de
parler sécurité ils ont le devoir de
s'assurer que les mesures sont prises et
ils on rendre compte au conseil de
surveillance sur
l'intervention de de Madame Didier
elle rejoint au moins sur la forme celle
de Monsieur revet vous me dites mais au
fond est-ceil y a des choses qui peuvent
être améliorées je je cite de mon point
de vue des choses qui peuvent être
améliorées le degré d'intégration oui je
pense que le degré d'intégration peut
être renforcé sans porter atteinte à
l'indépendance des fonctions
essentielles
de je pense que le volet financier du
projet peut-être rendu plus robuste par
des mesures complémentaires qui vont
permettre de stabiliser la
dette je pense que le volet social il se
nourrira de vos travaux en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat et je
pense que sur les responsabilités
d'autorités organisatrices de plein
exercice le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale peuvent clarifier et aller
plus loin sur les responsabilités
d'autorité organisatrices de plein
exercice c'est le sens de l'intervention
aussi de de Monsieur ris qui a insisté
beaucoup sur la question des moyens des
ressources il faudra un jour que les
régions estent une ressource propre pour
financer les
TER
enfin quelques autres interventions
monsieur alainouper a posé beaucoup de
questions si vous avec votre permission
monsieur houper j' j'en relève une ou
deux ou trois qui sont me semble-t-il
celles sur lesquelles je peux apporter
des éléments
d'information dans la dette les fameux
34 milliards de RFF il n'y a ou les 7
milliards de l'F il n'y a rien sur les
retraites désormais la caisse de
retraite est une caisse d'État c'est la
réforme menée par le précédent précédent
gouvernement qui a transféré la caisse
de retraite à l'état deuxièmement
l'harmonisation sociale européenne je je
trouve que là vous pointez quelque chose
de
fondamental il faut quand on aura
harmonisé en France il faut harmoniser
en Europe sinon ça veut dire qu'on va se
retrouver dans une espèce de guerre
stupide entre les réseaux
entre une guerre des moins 10 ans et ce
qui se passe dans le routier moi me
consterne dans le routier c'est le moins
an
social qui vient turber le marché des
autres États-membres qui eux ont des
équilibres sociaux qui ont été décidés
souvent par la loi ou
par les conventions collectives c'est un
bazar que moi je ne sais pas expliquer
au salariés et donc je pense que dans le
ferroviaire il faut du dialogue social
européen et une harmonisation sociale
ferroviaire et on y prend toute notre
part vous avez dit le train est cher il
a la réponse moi je je essaie de la
pratiquer tous les jours pour baisser
les prix il faut baisser les coûts sinon
ça fait de la
dette et vous avez enfin demander qu'on
accentue la pression sur les opérateurs
de télécom c'est le travail de RFF mais
je vais avec mon collègue Jacques roport
on va remettre la pression puisque c'est
eux qui pratiquent ces accords
d'itinérance le long des voies sur la
question sur les points les remarques de
Monsieur ris je suis très en phase euh
oui il y a une différence entre un op et
une autorité organisatrice et la SNCF a
mis trop de temps à totalement
l'intégrer aujourd'hui Alain leverne qui
est le patron des TER termine un projet
de décentralisation de la SNCF qui fait
que chaque président de région aura face
à lui d'ici la fin de l'année un
responsable TER qui ne peut plus jamais
dit dire je réfère à Paris ou à ma
direction centrale il n'y a plus
d'excuses possibles c'est le directeur
régional qui est en charge de la
totalité des réponses il maîtrise les
effectifs il maîtrise les moyens
financiers il est responsable des
objectifs de qualité de
service sur le modèle DSP moi je suis
très en phase aussi sur la question des
ressources je l'ai dit un mot sur la
dette alors sur la
dette au
fond je je dirais que sur endettement et
endettement faut même faire la
différence nous sommes aujourd'hui
surendettés ça signifie que nous
risquons de devoir réemprunter pour
assumer la charge de notre dette les
taux d'intérêt sont très bas s'il s'ils
remontent nous serons en situation de
surendettement c'est pour ça que
l'objectif de stabilisation est vital
mais pardon de le dire crumement il
suppose que les moyens financiers
disponibles dans ce pays soient
consacrés à la maintenance et à la
modernisation du réseau
existant et qu'on réduise la voilure sur
la construction de lignes
nouvelles deuxièmement il suppose notre
effort de performance je l'ai dit de
fois 500 millions d'euros nous nous
engagerons par un contrat de performance
signé avec l'État qui sera un contrat
public sur le contenu de ces 500
millions 500 millions réseaux 500
millions pour l'entreprise de
service et enfin il suppose je l'ai dit
sans doute que l'État puisse faire sa
part du chemin nous avons fait des
propositions
proposition la proposition que les
dividendes versé soit réinvesties
pendant un certain nombre d'années pour
accélérer la stabilisation de la dette
et proposition que l'impôt sur les
sociétés qui est versé aujourd'hui soit
lui aussi
affecté à la stabilisation de la dette
cette question de la dette est
absolument centrale absolument centrale
et les étape de stabilisation est une
première étape
nécessaire enfin euh en m'excusant cher
président d'avoir été peut-être un peu
long sur les deux dernières questions
celle de de Madame
Escoffier patrimoine foncier qu'est-ce
qu'on peut rapporter entre guillemets
avec des sessions intelligentes nous
pensons nous pensons qu'on peut
rapporter de l'ordre de 150 à 200
million d'euros par an en faisant
attention que vous avez adopté une loi
qui prévoit des sessions dans le domaine
ferroviaire à tarif
préférentiel pour les logements sociaux
et on en tient compte et on le fera de
cette manière là et puis la mise en
cohérence des différentes lignes des
différents services moi je je pense que
là vous pointez quelque chose de très
très important c'est la
nécessité que les futures autorités
organisatrices de plein exercice soient
moins
nombreuses
avec un ressort plus vaste pour pouvoir
elle-même faire ce travail de mise en
cohérence parce que quand on voit des
bus départementaux en concurrence avec
des TER régionaux et avec des centrales
de
mobilité qui viennent d'agloot on se dit
que l'argent public n'y trouve pas son
compte donc là encore retour vers la
réforme territoriale et enfin sur la
question
finale de Monsieur boissinau
le mur de travaux aura-t-on les moyens
je vous donne la précision que votre
question me
semblappel les 500 millions d'euros de
RFF ou du futur SNCF réseau sont des
économie non pas sur la modernisation et
la maintenance mais essentiellement sur
nos achats sur nos frais de structure et
sur des duplications pour vous en citer
une il existe aujourd'hui tant qu'on est
séparé il existe un contrat de gestion
de l'infrastructure qui fait plus de
1000 pages et qui nécessite plusieurs
dizaines de contrôleurs de gestion au
plan central et régional pour régler le
balai entre RFF et SNCF Infra et des
exemples comme ça on en a des dizaines
de gens qui travaillent dur pour des
choses qui ne présentent aucun intérêt
en terme de service public et de qualité
et
enfin enfin faire grandir les recettes
merci d'avoir soulevé ce sujet là dans
le projet que que je porte à l'intérieur
de la SNF qui s'appelle excellence 2020
qui a été adopté il y a maintenant 8
mois le chiffre qui concerne le
développement c'est 1 Millard 300
million d'euros dans la période 1illard
300 million d'euros de développement les
train de la vie quotidienne priorité
absolue y compris les
Intercités
deuxièmement être capable d'offrir un
service de bout en bout c'est-à-dire
être capable d'offrir là où c'est
nécessaire des trains des trames des
métros des bus des transports à la
demande toute la chaîne pour que les
Français et d'autres choix que la
voiture individuelle et enfin
l'international l'international
aujourd'hui c'est 25 % du chif d'affair
presque 10 milliards entre 9 et 10
l'engagement que j'ai pris c'est de
porter ce chiffre 33 % d'ici 2017 pour
que la France soit encore plus
qu'aujourd'hui un champion reconnu des
systèmes de mobilité au plan mondial
avec derrière le chiffre d'affaires les
exports et
l'emploi merci monieur je pense
que je crois qu'on peut vous remercier
de de la sincérité et de de l'effort que
vous avez fait dans vos précisions et je
pense que je pense que tous mes cèg on
pu apprécier votre votre intervention et
vos réponses voilà je ne doute pas que
ce qui s'est exprimé ici représente en
tout cas au départ de l'analyse de ce
texte une volonté forte politique de
pouvoir contribuer à une réforme qui est
absolument nécessaire et j'espère que
tous ensemble nous porterons ce projet
indispensable voilà alors merci à vous
pour vous décontracter un petit peu
peut-être un petit peu de régolice ah
pardon ah ça va me décontracter
heureusement que vous le
précisez comment dire les choses il faut
les dire poliment il faut les dire avec
Tacte et mesures il faut les dire avec
le
sourire euh mais j'ai pas beaucoup le
sourire non plus parce que je je vais
commencer par dire une chose hein euh
avec Jacques
Rapoport on a tenu ensemble un conseil
d'administration avec les
administrateurs de RFF et les
administrateurs de SNCF sur cette
affaire le
lendemain et les représentants des
260000 salariés du
groupe le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il y a quand même une proportion des
salariés qui ne savent plus dans quel
monde on vit qui ont été
choqués d'être de voir leur travail qui
est un travail plutôt d'expertise avec
du professionnalisme des questions
techniques liées à la sécurité expédier
en un emballement de de quelques
heures dans lequel les faits ont très
vite
disparu au profit des réactions des
emballements des demandes des uns et des
autres et donc je je veux dire devant le
Sénat que les cheminau ont été
extrêmement choqués pour nombre d'entre
eux de d'un tel
emballement et et d'une
telle difficulté à revenir au fait et
j'ajoute avec un peu la même émotion que
la presse internationale est
catastrophique parce qu'évidemment la
presse internationale disent en gros les
Français savent pas faire des
train et que au moment où on se bat sur
tous les marchés avec Alstom avec
bombardier avec Transdev avec la RATP
avec l'ingénierie française qui est la
première du monde dans C domaine là
il va nous falloir des mois pour aller
expliquer en Malaisie en Angleterre en
Australie que c'est une polémique
franco-française qu'il faudrait savoir
décrypter et reconvaincre que les
Français savent faire des trains et
savent faire des quais et savent mesurer
donc ayant dit ces deux éléments là qui
moi me perturbent et me touche
énormément je reviens aux choses on a
remis un rapport qui est totalement
transparent puisqu'il est en
ligne ce rapport comporte 150 pages de
pièces
jointes que tous les journalistes tous
les responsables politiques tous les
Français peuvent consulter dans lequel
il y a une totale transparence sur ce
sujet depuis 2008-
200009 qu'est-ce qui en ressort de ce
rapport c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre
Frédéric
cuviler et je le résume pour pas être
trop long non les trains ne sont pas
trop larges
bien sûr que non ils sont pas trop
larges pour une raison simple ils ont
été homologués par l'État
l'établissement public de sécurité
ferroviaire le 23 février on pense que
les gens de le PSF aussi ne n'ont pas de
de décimètres ils savent pas calculer un
gabarit donc oui les trains sont
conformes au gabarit et celui les deux
qui ont décidé du choix du train Bernard
soulage Martin Malvi qui ont présidé la
Commission d'appel
d'offre assume ce choix ils l'ont dit
publiquement mais ça n'a pas été
beaucoup entendu ni relayé donc les
trains sont
conforme deuxièmement le ministre l'a
rappelé nos qua les qua des 3000 gardes
de France il datent de toutes les
époques certains ont 150 ans d'autres
ont 1 an ils ont tous les formats en
longeur en longueur largeur hauteur ils
ont tous les formats et par conséquent
quand on introduit un nouveau train
futile conforme au gabarit international
un quai qui a 150 ans il y a peut-être
une chance qu'and 150 ans il est bougé
de quelques centimètres et des voies qui
n'ont pas
été retouché depuis 20 ans entreetemp il
y a eu le climat les inondations la
sécheresse et bien il est possible qu'il
faille les redresser faire passer une
boureuse pour déplacer la voie de 2 cm
ou 3 cm
le seul élément qui aurait été gênant
dans l'affaire c'est si des qua récents
des qu fait il y a 2 ans 3 ans 5
ans si c'est qu là aurait dû être raboté
on a trouvé tenez-vous bien un cas
peut-être en pasa peut-être un deuxè et
une incertitude sur le 3è on a peut-être
trouvé un qu de qu TR qu sur lequel on
s'est loupé mais ça n en aucune manière
l'emballement auquel on a assisté trème
chose
ça n'est une surprise pour personne
j'engage tout le monde à regarder les
échanges de courriers et des élus sont
exprimés Antoine hert vice-président
transport de la région Alsace a expliqué
mais il a pas été beaucoup entendu que
cette affaire est connue depuis 2009 que
lui s'en est emparé qu'il a depuis le
début comme Alain Rousset demandé
qu'aucune charge ne soit portée au
compte des régions et il a eu
satisfaction c'est RFF qui paye sur ses
investissements propres
alors puisqu'il n'y a jamais de fumé
ou plutôt de feu sans fumé de fumé sans
feu de fumer sans feu merci il y a
jamais de fumer sans feu faut donc
trouver un feu donc on a cherché un feu
on en a trouvé un mais c'est pas les
trains trop larges c'est pas
les3 c'est pas le scoop de dernière
minute c'est quoi c'est qu'effectivement
entre 2009 et 2011 c'està-dire
postérieurement au choix qui a été
effectué par la commission malvie
soulage
et avant 2011 où cette question a été
reprise avec sérieux il y a eu 2 3 ans
où les deux établissements public qui se
faisait une guerre ouverte n'ont pas
travaillé cette question correctement
oui oui c'est vrai donc j'ai ma part de
responsabilité dans le fait qu'entre
2009 et 2011 nous n'avons pas travaillé
correctement entre à l'époque Huber
duuménil et
moi cette faute entre guillemets
a-t-elle eu des conséquence là encore le
rapport l'établi heureusement non
puisqueà partir de
2011 nous avons recommencé à travailler
ensemble les travaux ont été faits et il
n'y a pas de
situation où cette absence de travail
commun est retarder la mise en service
du Régiolis il n'y a pas de situation ou
plutôt comme dans asterx on en trouve
une rassurez-vous trouve toujours
l'exception qui confirme la règle on en
a trouvé une entre Tarbe et montrégeot
où il y a un problème de circuit de voie
de passage et niveau qui n'est pas réglé
et qui retarde de quelques mois sur la
section Tarbe montrégeot la mise en
service du régiolice et donc là-dessus
il faut qu'on accélère les choses et
c'est l'engagement qu' a
pris Jacques Rapoport et dernier mot le
fond du problème de cette affaire mais
al on a été des très mauvais
communicquants sans doute he le fond de
cette affaire c'est améliorer l'accès
des FA fauteuil roulant des poussettes
des familles des seiors de tous les gens
qui ont du mal à se déplacer au train
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que le quai
et le train soi séparé de quelques
centimètres mais pas trop de centimètres
parce que si c'est trop de centimètres
la roue du fauteuil roulant la roue de
la poussette ou la personne qui a une
canne ne peut pas utiliser le train sans
assistance et donc tout le travail qui a
été fait par la commission soulage
malvie ça a été de regarder comment on
faisait un train conforme au gabarit qui
pouvait améliorer l'accès des fauteuils
des poussettes des personnes qui ont du
mal à se déplacer et quand on va sur le
terrain aujourd'hui le
Régiolis est largement soutenu par les
associations de personnes handicapées
Patrick toulemet qui est là-dessus une
référence absolue le comité consultatif
des handicapés et à la SNCF tous ces
gens-là se sont prononcés sur ce train
et ont soutenu le projet parce que ce
train facilite l'accès des personnes à
mobilité réduite au service public
ferroviaire donc voilà le ministre a
pris des décisions qui me semblent bonne
il a dit plus
jamais
d'absence de travail coopératif donc au
moment où on commande un train il faut
que les études entre le quai et le train
est été
terminé le ministre a dit
financement confirmé par les
investissements sur fond propres de RFF
donc ça ne coûte pas 1 € aux usagers pas
1 € au collectivité régionale et il nous
a demandé parce que c'est le fond du
problème d'aller devant chaque conseil
régional présenter
l'avancement du schéma
d'accessibilité régionale pour montrer
que dans ce pays
les trains vont être de plus en plus
accessibles au fauteuil aux poussettes
et aux personnes à mobilité réduite et
que c'est bien ça dont on doit parler
parce que c'est ça le problème et c'est
ça la perspective heureuse d'aujourd'hui
voilà pardon j'en ai parlé avec un peu
de comment dire un peu de d'engagement
mais c'est une affaire qui nous a fait
mal et qui nous a fait mal à
notre identité de cheminau merci
monsieur le Président voilà je pense que
c'est la conclusion encore une fois
merci de ce dernier volet de notre
audition et bon courage et à très
bientôt merci à tous merci beaucoup
votre contribution voilà pour cette
audition de Guillaume Pépi le patron de
la SNCF qui avait donc été entendu par
les sénateurs de la commission du
développement durable essentiellement
sur la réforme ferroviaire ce texte qui
réorganise les forces de Réseau ferré de
France et de la SNCF un texte qui a
suscité beaucoup de remous auprès des
chemineaux suscité de nombreuses grèves
avant l'été mais qui a été
définitivement promulgué au mois d'août
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaire